hey guys I recently had a question
relating to the blood type diet versus
the body type diet what's the difference
okay
now there's a book sold ten million
copies eat right for your blood type
okay
and on the outside it looks really
legitimate it looks scientific it looks
like there's a technology to it because
they're breaking down for different
diets based on your blood type Type A
where you're doing more vegan meals
plant-based type B blood we're doing
plant base plus some meats but without
chicken or pork avoiding wheat in corn
okay
type A B you're doing seafood tofu dairy
beans type o higher protein some fruit
paleo okay so basically they're the
technology is all based on your blood
type
but if you look at their research there
isn't very much research it's actually
very weak if any research and the author
also throws in some data about your
personality to being affected by the
blood type with which you lost me right
there because there's no way that your
blood type is going to affect your
personality your emotional level your
behavior it's not going to do that so
despite selling 10 million copies
obviously some people got some really
good results where they wouldn't have
kept buying this book it had it wouldn't
have spread but if you kind of look at
these diets you're cutting out a lot of
junk food
you're cutting out a lot of foods that
make you fat so that's probably why it
works for some people so it's not that
people don't get some results on that
okay so that's my opinion on the blood
type diet okay so now let's talk about
this science behind body types okay so
what I observed is that you notice that
if you look around a lot of you have
different shapes out there right and
there's four primary shapes you have
people that hold weight and the stomach
and then some people that actually have
a protruding belly people that gain
weight in the hips some people that gain
weight all over and not in any one
location so I was very curious about why
that is so what I do
it was I got my hands on nearly every
single book on Endocrinology that has
been written okay and I found like for
example when you have high cortisol you
can see the picture of the person's
belly where the fat goes right so so you
can see a female here there's a picture
of someone that has too much cortisol
you can see this body shape found that
interesting and if you look at someone
with liver damage they can get this
condition called ascites which is fluid
that builds up in a sac around the gut
and so they have a potbelly a lot of
people have this and then you can get a
fatty liver which then spills over and
it can give you visceral fat so that can
also come from the liver and then I do
know that estrogen dominance will
actually put fat around the hips and the
thighs okay if you have low estrogen you
don't accumulate fat in that location
then we have the thyroid and if the
thyroid becomes sluggish then you gain
weight we're all over so there's various
pictures of the shape that someone would
go into if they had a problem with this
gland okay so then I research and what
type of foods would improve the liver
function what type of foods would help
lower cortisol what type of foods are
anti estrogen ik and what type of foods
are really good for the thyroid
developing some type of technology to
support these shapes okay yeah that was
in the first book here's the second book
right here it's called the new body type
guide which is an upgrade from the seven
principles of fat burning okay and I
made some significant important changes
that I want to talk about so what I was
missing in my first book was at the
foundational eating plan that would
address one of the biggest problems out
there which is high levels of insulin or
insulin resistance so I needed some type
of basic reference so what we did is we
use the definition of the word food okay
and I want to read this to you food is
that which is eating to sustain life
provide energy and promote the growth
and repair of tissues and the derivation
of the word food is nourishment which
comes from providing nutrients to the
body okay so basically we need food to
provide and
and nutrients okay so let's first talk
about fuel okay there's two types of
fuel you can run the body on ketones or
glucose okay we already know the person
has been running in glucose their whole
life but here's the thing if you were
breastfed you started out in ketosis
breastfeeding is a natural thing for us
to start out on and when an infant is
fed breast milk they go right into
ketosis so our bodies really were meant
to run in a ketones not glucose and
that's why we have such a huge reserve a
fat to live off of and we have such a
small amount of stored glucose okay as
glycogen just simply because their
bodies are not designed to you know keep
beating every hour and a half and to be
able to then combine in a minute fasting
with ketosis now we're kind of mimicking
what our bodies are really designed to
do not consume meals every hour and a
half it's a very unnatural you create a
lot of problems when you do that so we
have the providing energy from ketosis
part but then what we want to do is we
want to make sure that that eating plan
has all of the required nutrients and
that's why we kind of enhance the a
traditional keto plan and made a healthy
version of that we call healthy ketosis
okay so healthy ketosis in the minute
fasting is the basic plan that everyone
starts on and then in two weeks we will
tweak that plan with your specific body
type okay this is the icing on the cake
well maybe I shouldn't talk about icing
on the cake but if you have a liver
problem then maybe we can support the
liver with certain types of nutrients or
foods sanding with the drean all same
thing with the ovary okay so I hope that
cleared up the difference between body
types and blood types
so I want to know what you're interested
in as far as future video click the link
down below and share some ideas I want
to hear